TO
TO JAYLEN BROWN, UP FAKE AND A
SHOT THAT'S DOWN AND HART WHIPS.
TATUM STOPS TOP SIDE FIRE AND
FILL IT.
A TRI NICE.
SADDIQ, FALL AWAY FILLS FILL IT.
>> George: BROWN INSIDE.
ON THE ATTACK WITH THE TURN AND
SMART TO THE LANE.
SMART TO THE RIMIM FREE-THROW.
CORY JOSEPH INSIDE BOUNCES TO
HAMIDOU WITH THE BASKET. 75th' Y
TEAM AS WELL.
AS IN BROWN TO DRIVE.
AND A LOB.
AND ROBERT
PUTS IT DOWN, TRIES TO GET
BASELINE, HIS HAMSTRING,
MEANTIME, CELTICS GO TO JAYLEN
BROWN A FIRES,
FILLS IT UP.
THE LONG GUN GOES FORIRS CHECKEY
LYLES, CAN'TIN THE LANE TO HORF.
JALEN BROWN IS DOING IT.
>> George: JACKSON TO THE
RICHARDSON ON THE WING TO WIDE.
THAT REQOR
THE BIG MAN.S TO THE LANE, STOPS
AND FIRES AND BOSTON.
TATUM WITH THEDOWED BECAUSE
BOSS UPON TON OFF THE CHARTS.
IF YOU LOOOO THE HIGH
GLASS AND THE SCOUR FOR DENNIS S
CLAIM.
30%.EASTERN CONFERENCE, N
CONTINUE
TO THE
LEFT HAND TKR*EUL DRIBBLE DRIVE
OFF THE NOW 4. SOME HANG HAMIDOU
SIDELINE T.
HANDS IT OFF TO CORY JOSEPH.
TATUM THE DRIVE.
MISFIRES BUT IT LANE FOR A JAMA.
LAYS IT IN. AT 10.
KILL WITNESS DRIVES, HE
KILLIAN HAYES.
FREE-THROWS.
McGRUDER.
>> George: KILLIAN INSIDE IF A
OLYNYK.
KELLY GRABBED HIM AND MADE THE
SHOT ANYWAY AND
DEFENSER.
KILLIAN WITH THE DRIVE.
LYLES, FROM THE BASKET, DOUBLE .
SADDIQ TO THE BASKET, SCOOPS ANT
KILLIAN.
SHOT CLOCK RUNNING OUT. SADDIQ.
ISAIAH STEWART ALONE RIM, TAPPEN